this is Stephens birthday um it's got my
reaction to it no that's me uh it it's
fine um it's fine
I guess it's good to know more about
saying because I forgot about that one
episode where he like really ages
rapidly it was another birthday episode
to a nature's an old man and everything
you know and it's something to just sort
of let go they definitely talked about
for a while now they're kind of bringing
it back again um so it's nice to see
that addressed and I I think they're
trying to talk about because the person
that does Stephens voice is a boy right
any is a like you know a kid it's not a
grown woman or anything hell of AI know
I've never actually looked up I'm I the
voice actors she sure it's a boy um you
know and that kid you know it's gonna
grow up in the voice is gonna change so
but in a car - how do you do that yeah I
mean you can technically draw him a
little different but you know he he's
kind of this weird anomaly so you have
to address that somehow and it looks
like the age fluctuation thing like it
can go backwards or forwards whatever
but I think they're trying to show now
like it can happen kind of from you know
naturally like you can at you get older
cuz now at the end he has a pair and you
know I think that's more like hey we're
probably gonna leave him like mostly the
same design but his voice changes that's
just the geminus growing up whatever in
a you know undecidable amount of episode
slash timeframe that we have for the
show um so you saying you think they're
gonna make it like bobby from king of
the hill
no wait he never aged that was the funny
thing about I know that very well
yeah the friend did um he went 380 right
yeah Bobby uh yeah he really did just
like never grow up did he yeah he just
says take cuz some kids really are late
bloomers and hell even some like you
know the voice never changes and they
look you know that's definitely what
they were indicating with Bobby but um
yeah it's one of those things where it's
like I'm sure it's to like help some
sort of you know future problem that
could happen because and my guess would
be they don't even know what they're
gonna do with that but I
I think the idea of the age regression
and getting older and younger is an
interesting one
oh no he's a baby it's like well that's
what most women think they're doing in
the relationship she should get used to
it um but I like it when she thinks he's
shrunk down to microscopic um at Ella I
like to be you know when they lower the
voice and everything um so but I guess
it's good to address too because like I
think cuz they don't know what he is or
how he's gonna age whatever that you
know it's like well in a relationship
yeah how would that work are you just
gonna you know what is her attachment
now is she gonna be a it's like I'm
raising the children
oh well that's manchild um but yeah I
mean I it's good to address there's a
few funny scenes I really I've never
seen like where they get a baby seat and
Emily shows amethyst I thought that was
pretty funny
um so not want that job no I can say I'm
an either well I think it also dresses
too because something I was kind of
wondering I kind of feeling but like you
know when the gems take on different
forms vinegary amethyst you know when
she could stretch out and everything
else like well why want they do that all
the time then why don't his show as it
does strain on you you know there's only
a certain amount that you can do so um
open a few flow answers there and it's
you know it's about it I mean I can't it
wasn't particularly like dramatic filled
or like super funny or anything I mean I
think it's just kind of what it is just
kind of a little explanation a few jokes
few laughs she cries OH
paratis magic he's a baby indeed
yeah um nothing it's like what do you
really I mean it's not bad it's fine
it's problem with a cartoon like this
with so many episodes as you get an
episode once awhile where it's is like
oh when I was just a fun little thing
this is like I didn't ain't get anything
particularly deep I did like at the end
it's okay if I donate and she's like it
doesn't matter and I'm like uh soured
you were implying earlier but I think
what she very yeah I felt very bad for
Stephen than those scenes where she's
totally like getting into it and like
just like Oh Stephen you're so tall and
but
she even let me he was lying to her too
and I think it's one of those things
where it's like I think it'd be like
nice for it to happen but once you saw
every Drive she's like no no you know
what if I gotta live with this this is
really fine
you know that that's kind of what I got
out of it I don't feel it like yeah I
mean or anything Harlem
yeah I just you need smaller episodes to
I mean yeah there's something wrong
there this is I always hate being put in
this position where just like oh it's
retro I say retro so maybe we should was
held up doing this one just combined it
with the next step because I feel like
this is very little to say I mean maybe
I mean there's a couple things I'm sure
we filled up whatever about of minutes
oh we got there um but uh yeah it's it's
fine um 30 seconds Sabbath Wow man I
thought his idea of time was bad else 30
seconds Wow um so yeah that's about it
uh-oh the only other thing I'll add is
please please yeah the father driving in
the car just like this usually works
that does work a million laughs Janice
you know waiting in kids asleep when I
was driving Mecca
yeah my my sister-in-law has a baby that
works our own MacGyver Jim Jay Roz he
has a baby that works it's like driving
in a car for some reason we'll put
babies to sleep like instantly it's
bright like a camel rocking motion or
zapping and they have to be in one spot
I mean there's very limited space you
can run around in a car um I think the
lighting is I think it's the motion that
that you were that white noise and the
motion of just driving just yeah the
white noise - probably plays a big part
the more I think about honestly driving
myself I I put myself to sleep I'm
actually hazard on the road that oh
that's good hop behind the wheel necks
again oh I'm just like oh so I'll Drive
oh I did the last thing I'll say cuz
I've been very brought this up before
every time I see Stephens dad I feel so
warm because that son you know that
sunburn on him but just like guy just
wants wet looking at that guy cuz I hate
sunburns every time I see I'm like hey
man I drives me nuts that's true so is
no yeah bottom of the barrel
by chance why
to throw that out there so um yeah
that's about it
I'm we all got something like what three
episodes no no Ronaldo no Ronaldo that
isn't flush this is a filler episode
that much to talk about but no Ronaldo
so if I'm right looking at the list I
think we only have like three episodes
left so I mean we're getting uh they're
more running currently though I don't
know I mean I think the last one I saw
at least I was again the wiki page or
whatever said the last ones like January
when it ran the last episode so I have
no I I mean I know more are coming
obviously but yeah in terms of what was
that episode January the one we got here
no no no no um like the lack okay I mean
we'll figure it out after we turn the
camera off but you know something I'm
pretty sure it's on like three left so
we're kind of getting to the the
homestretch here
um but yeah so I'm sure the next three
or four I'd be I have a little bit more
to talk about but yeah that's about it
and we'll see you ah then